well the apartment justice just
announced plans to appeal a San
Francisco judge's decision ordering the
continuation of the daca program a
single unelected federal judge suddenly
in charge of the entire country's
immigration policy somehow DOJ is
fighting that meanwhile though we have
new and fascinating stats tonight on
immigration both legal and illegal and
how it intersects with crime in America
as it often does
according to federal numbers released
today America's terror threat is clearly
among other things an immigration issue
of the five hundred forty nine people
convicted of terrorists between 9/11 and
the end of 2016
fully 73 percent or immigrants many men
turd this country through chain
migration and the diversity lottery both
of which allow immigrants here without
regard for their skills or how well they
would integrate into American society
and clearly many are not integrating the
DOJ estimates that more than twenty
people in this country are murdered
every year in honor killings almost
always by family members who see them as
quote too westernized about 15-hundred
are put into forced marriages in this
country annually between 2003 and 2009
immigrants to the United States
committed about 70,000 sex crimes
none of these facts require we shut down
immigration no one's arguing that but
they do demand an honest discussion not
dismissive accusations of bigotry every
time somebody raises the subject you've
heard the response a thousand times shut
up dumb American illegal aliens are more
law-abiding than you are and way more
impressive and some fake study proves
that well not so fast
a new report released by John Lott of
the Crime Prevention Research Center
takes a close look at how illegal
immigration affected crime in one state
Arizona and the numbers are stark in the
state of Arizona illegal immigrants are
more than two and a half times more
likely to commit murder as US citizens
are there almost three times as likely
to commit manslaughter far more likely
to be convicted of a sex crime against
children as well as armed robbery
convicted illegal immigrants forty-five
percent more likely to be gang members
overall young illegal immigrants break
the law and not just immigration law the
rest of the laws at twice the rate of
American citizens so for at least one
state we know that illegal immigration
is directly linked to higher crime rates
these numbers deserve honest
discussion in the halls of power not
shrieks of bigotry and angry
declarations that all immigrants our
future Medal of Honor recipients the
fact that elites don't want to have that
conversation says everything about what
the real priorities are and you're not
on the list of priorities trust Attorney
General Jeff Sessions oversaw the
release of the DOJ terrorism report and
he joins us tonight mr. Attorney General
thinks coming up you know given these
numbers it does give new urgency I think
to the immigration negotiations going on
right now in Washington you were
involved in a number of efforts I think
in oh six oh seven thirteen to scuttle
attempts at amnesty and during that time
I remember you saying the Washington
establishment supports any kind of
border enforcement as long as it doesn't
work what did you mean by that
that's exactly correct anytime a
proposal like a wall or to fix this idea
that you can claim you're afraid to go
home and you get to stay in the United
States or you have problems where we
provide subsidies to people who come
illegally the more you subsidize it the
more you get of something these kind of
failed policies are just never going to
work and the American people don't
believe in it
and we've been trying to reform it and
every time you come up with a reform
that works gets blocked and so President
Trump has said we need we have
immigration and we want immigration but
we want to vet these people we want to
know who they are and make sure they're
gonna be productive people people who
are flourished in America who are going
to not be terrorists not be criminals
and that's exactly correct for America
it's just unbelievable to me that we
have the resistance we're having today
to the reforms that are on the verge we
are close to having reforms that will
actually work today and that voters
voted for by the way in 2006 big issue
in this election Trump took it directly
to the American people it was a huge
factor in his victory yet the same crowd
that fought for the amnesty before is
still trying to scuttle good reforms
today so apparently here are features of
the proposal we're now looking at it
would fund just about 10% of the
proposed border wall about 70 miles at a
2,000 no enforcement basically you can't
deport anybody it would expand it chain
migration dreamers could bring their
relatives it makes a diversity lottery
more low-skilled it doesn't seem like
it's moving in the right direction
totally in unjustifiable that cannot be
that is not a proposal that has any
prospect of success they need to look at
the proposal at House Judiciary
Committee congressman good lad has
proposed that will work it will end the
illegality make a tremendous progress
toward ending illegality and make the
system work better that's what the
American people want and the objectors
the sanctuary cities the New Jersey
policy you just talked about those are
policies that favor illegalities they
subsidize illegality they encourage
illegality American people are sick of
that it's time to end it
the choice is clear and it's going to be
even clearer this year we're gonna have
some votes in Congress people need to be
held to account are you going to fix the
system create a system that protects
America we know that as you said
seventy-three percent of the people
who've been arrested for terrorism came
here were born abroad so if they had
been properly screened and rejected we
wouldn't have had these attacks in our
country so someone I spoke to would
direct knowledge said that in his
meeting with the President on
immigration Lindsey Graham summed up his
closing argument by reciting Emma
Lazarus's poem from the Statue of
Liberty not really a case that you'd
expect Republicans to be making why
aren't there more articulate Republican
members of the Congress making the case
that you just made well I wish there
were actually I think people need to get
focused on this we are not against
immigration the president is not against
immigration what the American people
won't have a right to and what's good
for America is a lawful system of
immigration and when we admit people to
our country we should be like Canada we
should evaluate them and make sure
they're going to be lawful they're not
threats to us they have the Education
and Skills level to prosper in America
that's good for them and good for
America what good does it do to bring in
somebody who
illiterate in their own country has no
skills and is going to struggle in our
country and not be successful that is
not what a good nation should do and we
we need to get away from it a good
debate needs to be happening this year
the president is right on the lottery
that's ridiculous how absurd is a bet
for policy for a great nation we need to
tighten up on our admission of people
from dangerous areas of the globe where
we can't vet where we have high numbers
of terrorists that live in those areas
we should certainly be more careful and
limit that kind of immigration it
strange I don't when you left this the
Senate it lost a maybe it's best voice
on it so thank you very much thank you I
appreciate it